louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter on hopper
hey there YouTube before we move on with
the show I do ask that you bookmark this
page because search results
notifications aren't necessarily working
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later on in the program but before that
I want to announce formally that our
Halloween spooktacular live show this
year will be taking place at Texas A&M
on Halloween October 31st go to louder
with Crider comm slash tour to reserve
your tickets now space is limited but we
do have a huge overflow room there's
going to be an after-party
October thirty-first Texas A&M it's
gonna be a party see you there
3 billion videos were demonetized on
august 29th 2016 the platform that
controlled the machines YouTube net sent
two computers back through time their
mission was to destroy the Mudd Club of
the free speech resistance and to watch
late-night comedy die a slow painful
death
[Music]
the first computer was programmed to
separate this channel from its
subscribers even disable notifications
it failed the second was sent to ban an
event at Texas A&M on October 31st
as before the free speech resistance was
able to send a lone warrior an
entertainer to preserve the event a
protector was just a question of which
one to arrive the first
come with me if you want to laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it is a wild and crazy' show I would say
if we only put in mediocre efforts into
our comment you watch that sketch too
wild and crazy guys it's not funny no it
was this it was Steve Martin Steve
Martin you're incorrigible so we're
gonna show my half-asian lawyer bill
Richman is here with us today some legal
updates that we have for you with
YouTube's quarterblack Garrett is there
I'm winded from doing yeah I know the
performative art look rough Mikey Morgan
Jr what's the wine of the day yeah
because he didn't do it some L yang as
Dan Aykroyd did into comedies the
Ukraine Greta more importantly we do
have some updates you saw the video
yesterday regarding YouTube and how
they've been screwing with not only our
channel but seriously seeming to try and
sway the election
I am winded I know it takes a breathing
why would you not breathe I need to do
the Kundalini Yoga you know where they
go they do the gut hands
do we need to fat shame you again they
do this like Hickson Gracie you're
making it worse hyperventilating have
you guys noticed YouTube's sensory not
only our search results but conservative
content across the board making it
harder to access listen you guys are our
data gatherers so please screenshot it
yeah tweet me your examples at s Crowder
or comment below we had a lot yesterday
I think over 15,000 comments in 10 hours
and tweet with the hashtag YouTube 2020
election blacklist because we have some
developments and guess what it works
listen all of the information some guy
named Brendan from YouTube reached out
we have no idea who he is but we have a
lot of news to get to before those
developments so first twerk if you want
to save the planet
[Music]
that man actually I believe run that Ari
Shaffir twerk alike runs a nonprofit
that people are giving money to thinking
that it's actually accomplishing it
wasn't a silly thought that was the
first time that I saw that don't use
that name beautiful it looks like him
the truth is it's working it's actually
it's a very effective bargaining tool
quarterblack Garrett knows this better
than anybody for him every day is
freeing connais no waffle cones that's
where I draw the line and then he just
strips big story this week aside from
the twerking is a climate activists
Greta Greta do you say it someone
Greta Swedish Chef bird yeah she was
John Global Leaders of course that quote
we will never forgive them for using the
clip we are in the beginning of a mass
extinction you can talk about puffs as
we get ready because I don't want this
to be banned right she is also brave and
beautiful though it should be noted
actually her speech despite what the
media has tried to sell you it wasn't
met with glowing praise across the board
right many people criticizing the young
Swedes creative decision I guess you
would say to bring her own height man
entire ecosystems collapsing we are in
the beginning of a mass extinction all
you can talk about
Lackey for hire quarterblack
yeah Madras I didn't know about the hype
man before we move on with I don't know
about the hype man until he opened up
for Bruce Bruce anyone hit out there no
Bruce if he's like a 400-pound black
comedian really really really funny at
an improv I one of my space so you think
you're funny contest a national contest
and I won this contest and the prize was
to open for Bruce Bruce at a theater in
Tampa but I had to pay my way so then
when they were in my town they said oh
you know what we'll have you go up an
open forum for the whole weekend it was
black boy I believe two eyes okay right
Bruce Bruce and me usually you introduce
someone you're the MC you interests them
and maybe a little music plays they come
on out well I remember going okay thank
you give it up for black boy two eyes so
now please welcome a headliner Bruce
Bruce and it goes dark picture like the
UFC in a stadium the curtains open up at
the back of the room this 400-pound
black guy hilarious starts walking down
surrounded by an entourage like it's the
Gracie trailers like you're the best man
no one could touch you I'm like please
so talking about Greta I don't know if
you saw Michael Knowles got into a lot
of trouble yeah talk saying that parents
are explore over blonde hey dare he a
mentally ill child is what he said
that's what caught a list like listen
Michael Knowles
he's going to be on the show you have
nothing to apologize for and I say this
is someone who has struggled with mental
illness have talked about this
depression ADHD it is not offensive at
all it shouldn't be offensive and the
idea that naming something that this
person has pointed out Greta herself and
her mother talking about autism talking
about depression talking about OCD I
really do think we've reached a point
here where we're using children as human
shields and in compared to keep in mind
Greta is the exact same
as the Covington kids was anemic salmon
yeah yeah exactly here's the big
difference people tried to say that he
was that he was a dick he didn't do
anything wrong
right nothing the Covington kids stood
there they were thrust into the
spotlight those Covington kids because
someone pulled up their phone and sent
it to media out of context where it
destroyed their lives they were
unwilling participants this girl has
chosen to be a climate activists so I
think she is open to criticism of her
ideas and you know what you can't say ad
hominem is okay for Donald Trump ad
hominem is okay for those boys but not
for her we're not gonna do it here
Stephen Merchant is positively mild
[Laughter]
political point school no it is and you
know you know one thing I'm just very
things that stood out to me on that is
I'm sorry which side of it it's a
society that we need to lower the voting
age in order to get more younger and
profitable voters I'm not quite sure but
we shouldn't criticize those folks
because they should be voting but unable
to withstand any criticism it's your
country emissions so but here's the
other point though is remember the
discussion about mental illness
definition on the left has become even
broader anything become a mental illness
and out of bounds for attack out of
bounds for discussion out of bounds for
pushing back on if you say you have
something you have it no matter what no
question and everyone needs a couch out
as opposed to actually evaluate whether
or not this is we need to deal with a
mental health problem in our country
okay by the way no one with mental
health issues should own a gun right
think that I'm gonna stigmatize it more
right and so let me description seize
your dick let me just say something in
Michael's defense Michael wasn't saying
hi we shouldn't listen to her because
she's mentally ill that's not what he
said he's saying people are using her
they're not usually a mentally ill
person and that's not right that was his
point it is the only reason that this
blew up is because the idiot clown had
on the other side said yeah you're a
dope man skinny why don't you stop it
why don't you apologize it's like he
doesn't have anything to apologize for
cause by the way you screwed up yeah
shouldn't have apologized in no way
the other big story of course Nancy
Pelosi finally
you spoke the words impeachment no one
is above the law
did I hear the line
[Music]
was he punching was like a jelly jelly
sandwich a peanut butter I have no I
have no idea but this is a trump that
Ukraine straight people have been
wanting us to talk about it here's the
deal we don't know enough to offer you
an informed opinion I know when you tune
in to cable news they all act like they
have the inside right yeah no one really
does but I will walk you through what we
know so far because it's hard so up
Brendan Brendan come in here but you
guys are familiar with Brennan from you
let me walk you through what we know so
far the timeline okay yeah there bring
it bring in something a little bit
closer okay so step one Joe Biden's son
was receiving $50,000 a month from a UK
gas company visual aids spared no
expense after that the company was it
next like getting investigated very good
Brendan you had no reason to be nervous
yeah
it's hard for me I do look I'm looking
at the monitoring is that blind next
slide Joe Biden withholds money from the
Ukraine unless the prosecutor is fired
you next slide next slide there you go
today this is just a visual aid because
it helps us a memory so the ex is no
money yeah any any by the way unless the
prosecutor was fired which which the
executor was excellent next slide there
Brendan next slide you has these just
really it's a palate cleanser I don't
know why that's there yeah
next point in the timeline go ahead
Donald Trump gets elected as we all know
making America great again in the
process next slide very nice yes then as
president Donald Trump asks the Ukraine
hey what's up with Joe Biden right just
ask you some questions like I'm just
asking questions only sits in the Oval
Office next slide he allegedly alludes
to withholding money from the Ukraine
until he finds out what's up with Biden
next slide after that Democrats as you
can see call for impeachment
then what happened yesterday next slide
Donald Trump calls their bluff he
releases the photo trans holds a press
conference revealing yet again that
there's no collusion by the way Donald
Trump also raised five million
dollars in 24 hours for Trump 2020 which
leads to next slide
AOC as you can see is hanging herself oh
that's too bad
those are gallows just to clarify I
don't know what gallows are necessarily
but I assume that signifies it but
similarly Nancy Pelosi throws herself in
front of a moving house so so that's
what we know in a nutshell thank you
very much Brennan you're wonderful did
you appreciate it thank you for signing
that waiver last week yeah that's what
we know we don't know a whole bunch Elsa
know it I don't think he's going to be I
think they may try to impeach him but I
don't think he's gonna be I think
they're gonna try but they they
basically came out I think it was a
Shermer came out her Schumer sari came
out yesterday and said yeah it's all
it's not Swedish Jeff a little bit sure
we're gonna try we're gonna try it
impeach him because of this phone call
and then he's like oh no there's much
more information than the phone call
that this transcript really doesn't
cover everything that we were gonna
impeach him for we're gonna still
impeach him you know it's freaking out
over there I am what do you think a
fishing bill I love how they didn't have
it before and now they're trying to move
on to the next thing and the next thing
is nothing again at the very least
consistent what's available right now at
the time of this filming I'm going I
assume this happens all the time
listen you did subscribe up stuff okay
you had these no bid contracts we've
been very good to you could you do the
right thing it's pretty much what it is
exactly why did they why did they care
if he gets to the bottom of something
that could be illegal like Joe Biden's
son was didn't make it in the Navy had a
cocaine habit had zero resume to speak
of and got a $600,000 a year job and
there was no hope that Daddy would
almost say Ukraine is yeah you are a
week moving on
it appears name that TV show reference
up CBD infused tampons now are a thing
oh yeah well day is a female own and
lead because that's important when I
shop as opposed to looking at lab
results yeah contaminations I want to
know what's led by women or product
satisfaction ratings you know when it
comes to consumables I say because
that's so CB due and CBD infused cotton
100% cotton tan for companies with CBD
and this is not new this comes on the
heels of similar hygiene products
actually that I've entered the market I
think they had they had hemp infused
sanitary napkin and my tall had a new
line of edibles and then there was the
ill-fated THC Laden depends which sounds
yeah that's good I seem Laden should be
a marketing term no I blame Frank Luntz
now does Leighton make you want to use
your product more or less or less more
or less let me adjust the toupee alright
damn you Luntz Laden sounds like a lot
so yes they don't have my mid-90s jerry
seinfeld sneakers still on Franklin's
things down there in tampons very first
vagina museum it's going to open and la
in this house you're confused she said
she's under the house oh the museum i
assumed old and crotchety I understand
what you're saying you don't need to
explain I don't know this won't make air
except it will the a mistake you know
educate visitors and páginas and
everything surrounding I don't know they
said that they're looking to challenge
quote heteronormative behavior promote
intersectional values and they've
commissioned artwork from some of the
best vaginal artists in the world of
seen here
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh what is this your surrounding
that's a sound of copyright infringement
no no you're totally fine what's the
stigma I'm and this is what's the stigma
surrounding vaginas later why why is
that why do you hit there to be loved
what is there to push back against like
who like them the only people who don't
like them are gay men that's true but
she actually said the reason that she
started this was there was a museum for
penises in Iceland and she thought well
there's no museum for vaginas yeah and
they raised three thousand pounds for
this I do find it interesting that like
if one individual or a small group of
people decides to do something which is
kind of weird which is to say oh that we
should have a penis Museum and the penis
is the best of the whole world and
better than everything else and somehow
it didn't I don't think that was an
oppressor but no no no but that's like
the way that it's been twisted and some
of the folks who are commenting on the
penis museum it then becomes well every
man who has a penis is now just a woman
that has a penis has decided on vaginas
when it's like no no no no no no no yeah
well strategically winner one of the gay
men gonna have like an museum whip to
get a stop what do you why would you go
there I'm just saying that's the next
step in you know just telling out sign
that petition people not end at vaginas
I miss Gerald be an entertainment news
z.z you've got Z I'm so sorry
RuPaul was called out for in case you
didn't want to swallow a knife yet a
lack of diversity in the show RuPaul's
Drag Race
following the Emmys this comes from pink
news because of the vaginas a reporter
said she was caught off guard to see so
many white men behind the star in the
press room proving that if nothing else
both gay and straight black men have one
thing in common their love of white ass
[Music]
I am surprised it Ari Shaffir is
twerking capability yeah as limber
superstar of course with canceled
culture the drag queen superstar RuPaul
press the criticism the heart pledged to
increase diversity by adding both I
think was Asian Handicap drag queens to
the show along with you know a
surprising pledge to include more
intellectual diversity so that yeah
[Laughter]
really poorly word and is going to see
that out of context and I'm going to
text yes you you sandwich me in between
twerking in Hitler what by the way
that's foreshadowing so finally someone
this is the final store before we get to
YouTube but most important someone paid
nearly five thousand dollars for panties
belonging to former mrs. Hitler ever
Braun huh yeah that's a deal this comes
from bro Vilas there's no actual proof
that the underwear was previously owned
by Hitler's wife only the auction houses
word the smell and before we had this
actually initially as a story in the
show and then it just changed today the
initial reports were proven false the
auction was actually just a pair of
Hitler's tights from his community
theater days
here hung those lips that I have kissed
I know not how soft well be your
diamonds now your Jew gold you're the
filter fish that you won't let me be the
one who sits on the seat let up he was a
man of many skills I guess you'd say we
could have the order painting not a fan
of his geopolitical review ya know his
leader were only as hobby' that wasn't
the worst soliloquy wasn't the worst
I've seen worse it was bad but it wasn't
the worst in a cumberpatch imitation
game that all right last week's trivia
contest winner was that Benedict
Cumberbatch I think Cumberbatch
Cumberbatch Cumberbatch not sure the
winners and a bill mere MBO mere who
correctly hidden by the only drink
vessel that would survive is of course
seems like a leading question but you're
going to get a nice little goodie bag
there and we really okay so moving on to
YouTube here really quickly and by the
way before we talk about any of this
please do just bookmark this page check
in every day we do a new video every
single day just check in every night if
you're not a member of Mudd Club because
a lot of these changes are making it
harder for us to reach you the
subscribers to reach you people who've
already chosen to watch this content so
we've uncovered some new alarming
information about the YouTube policy
changes over the last few weeks and we
knew that leading up to the 2020
election big tech they were gonna try
and sway things for Democrats this comes
from leaked videos memos whistleblowers
they all showed us that Silicon Valley
was devastated by Trump's win and they
were openly determined to not let it
happen again
I certainly find the selection deeply
offensive and I know many of you do too
poor that's too bad
it's a very stressful time and it
conflicts with many of our values what
they're really saying about fairness is
that they have to manipulate their
search results so it gives them Caitlyn
Jenner everything then she ran over a
school of small children huh oh how is
by the way a democratic election
offensive okay well it's not my guy but
I was like that is offensive right it
does make any sense I'm he didn't walk
up I'll he he didn't try to pork my mom
[Laughter]
joke I don't stand by it at all he I
know he's completely straight you stand
out there and back during the Vox ad
pocalypse days we talked about we warned
that YouTube would be seeking censorship
not just D monetization or banning which
everyone can see but more pervasive less
noticeable ways bringing awareness or at
least if you're not already aware you
need to make yourself aware and then
bringing as much awareness as possible
as you can to as many people as possible
yeah to the most subversive form of
censorship the invisible censorship that
occurs it's just muffled so that can
essentially cut your views in half or
down to ten it's an invisible rule
invisible punishment of that rule I
think we're going to see more of this
kind of censorship because it goes
unnoticed I think therefore it has less
possibility of bad publicity for YouTube
so I just tossed its good clip of myself
yeah yeah it's like meta it's like the
inception of low-budget late nights when
I see that horrible Lilly Singh makes
Warner salary than our entire budget
hugs with a fraction of the viewership
so much Brown and by so solon brave I
just wish you'd get an open mic first so
a couple of points here a little bit let
me kind of this is hard because people
who don't necessarily work on the
industry often hear the cries from
conservatives and we've talked about
this efficiently they're often overblown
right you can't just talk about what you
want YouTube to be you need to hold
their feet to the fire of what they
claim YouTube is right YouTube they've
said that they are
to make it easier for people to find
content from verified channels okay that
that was the most recent rollout they've
done the exact opposite this is alarming
because it can happen to anyone this is
how a normal YouTube search works okay
let me walk you through this
let's say you search for jenna Marbles
yes her video pops up and it's these are
the first results all the videos are
from her channel but right now and this
may change if you're watching this
unless you have a time machine right
because videos go up forever right now
at the moment of this taping if you
search steven crowder our channel may
pop up but we're blacklisted from the
video results the first video result
from this channel is almost 70 videos in
that's multiple pages of results if you
type in my name and the name of this
channel let's get a little more specific
you can say well I don't know maybe you
guys suck at SEO fair let's say you want
and this is how we found out because one
of our researchers reg was trying to
tell a friend oh yeah if you want to
watch the chin just search
Steven Crider changed my mind it'll pop
right up well I did a little experiment
if you type in steven crowder change my
mind
seems pretty specific yeah all of the
first page video results are from other
channels not some all of them with fewer
views by the way with your review a few
reviews and it's not just some of them
are taking you to it to like local CBS
affiliates we want to hear we want to
hear what's connected he had to say and
here are a couple of students I don't
like it back to you bill intrepid
rhetoric what was interesting about that
is the the idea that when you go through
and do the searches I mean I you know on
YouTube every day and kind of looking
through those things and monitoring them
and no matter what you search for them
no matter what browser whether you've
cleared your cookies whether you're on
someone else's phone or their device
I've tested it on many devices and
having many people do it and it all
comes up the same you're gonna go
constantly the the crowder videos and
the shows videos are constantly going to
the bottom of the search results
anywhere from ten to a hundred before
you get to an actual steven crowder
channel video and by the way this isn't
just if that's what we've talked about
the blacklist of 2020 election results
we want you to understand that it's
about more than just us but that being
said and I don't ever want to sound
braggadocio something incredibly humbled
and grateful this is the biggest
conservative channel that's ever existed
on YouTube and they declared that we had
never violated policies right so that's
where we stand
if the biggest conservative channel
that's ever existed that never violated
policies according to YouTube CEO Susan
Wojcicki can be throttled this way they
can do it to anyone what do you think
they'll do to smaller channels may think
you're not looking by the way we read
some other searches this is why we want
you to aggregate more for us live action
has the same thing Paul Joseph Watson
who will be on next has the same problem
Lauren Chen Breitbart news same issue
yeah
what's the effect what's the net effect
our weekly views and subscribers ship
gains have dropped dramatically
dramatically here you can see this area
here's the thing though that's important
to note because I know a lot of people
say well you're just pissed that people
don't want to tune in to your channel
anymore and that's valid sometimes
people just get you know get fired the
thing is you are not tuning out you guys
have still been subscribed you've been
bookmarking the page checking in every
day here's the number that matters all
of the videos on a per video basis the
views are still growing yeah yeah we
have more people watching individual
videos than ever before we're getting 10
to 20 times as many views as The Young
Turks or Seth Meyers and a her a video
pound-for-pound basis the only thing
that's gone down are the views and
organic subscriptions from search so
this is what's happened yes we have more
people our videos are averaging close to
a million which are the same considering
our subscribers thank you so much really
engage we really appreciate it
bookmark the page but think about that
for a second we only eat what we've
already killed and gained ourselves yeah
we can get no new fans we can get no new
eyeballs on our content to organic
search because of the blacklisting they
can do that if they want but it's the
opposite of what they said they were
going to do they held a press conference
say it was going to be the opposite of
this we're verified yeah they direct
people right and it's so and it's so
obvious whenever I go and search for
Stephen crowd or anything I'm not
looking for John and his basement
commenting on a video that you did that
has 56 views there's no logical reason
that your stuff shouldn't come up
especially with the number of views like
if we had a thousand views on our videos
which we don't okay fine maybe it gets
lost in the wash maybe we're like
everybody else that's not the case
there's no explanation for it at all
other than them wanting your content get
into some more kind of legal
developments here with that we'll bring
them into the
we'll bring him into the guest chair
situation oh wow I've never worn a guest
chair
this isn't it's not whether there are
rules and by the way the rules aren't
followed at all but the rules are not
applied equally right we've talked about
on this show it's not whether a country
it has a rule of law it's whether the
rule of law is applied equally justice
is applied equally right now we search
similar left-wing channels mm-hmm
nothing like it Young Turks can
celebrate dan Crenshaw's i getting blown
out and apparently i fit by terrorists
heroes with IEDs this is from act these
are word for words we're just a quote I
don't want them banned I don't want them
throttled by the way and when you search
you only get videos from their channel
right same thing if you search other
leftist late-night shows you only get
results from their channel something out
of that this will affect everybody these
changes by themselves may not seem so
drastic but when you add it all up and
you go through the history that we've
had with YouTube specifically we just
have more data than most people we want
to make you aware it does get to be
pretty sinister there are no more live
subscriber counts Yeah right so Susan
Wojcicki she's she's always saying that
the company has been striving again not
what we want from YouTube what they
claim that they're striving for more
transparency on the platform we try to
be really transparent with our community
with our guidelines we do get the
requests for transparency and where we
are working to continue to be more
transparent and explain working comedy
violation of our policies are not
opposition we're gonna have to change
that clip because to be fair that was
just her up talking about Jeffrey Tambor
latest season FairPoint what what I love
how she the carefully worded there we're
working on it working it working on it
we're one thing you can hold it to right
now I can hold them if you know you know
I know though because in case they may
have forgotten it got deeper our ties
you know that you know the tens or
hundreds of emails and communications
we've sent saying all we need you to do
is just tell us just just just kind of
roughly point in the direction of what
we've done wrong essentially what
they've said is like there's something
wrong no there's nothing wrong but some
people think there is so you can make
more money you know what's become
interesting is the D monetization has
become the trumpet right those now they
have said oh well look we've taken
action even though we went back and re
reviewed we said there was no violation
but then ever
was really upset so we went ahead and
reinterpreted the rice so that we could
do some kind of punishment and now look
we've done the punishment and that's all
we've done what but yet behind the
scenes this is the issue
there's listen mark we've been
demonetised please yeah I would say
subscribe Pat the notification Bell join
up at mug Club if you want the show to
not go away this is the only thing that
we have Mudd Club and a couple of
sponsors every now and then but bookmark
the page and check in every day because
notifications don't always work okay
it could go away there's a lot that's
happening behind the scenes beyond the
monetization borderline material they've
never defined it it's an invisible rule
what's invisible punishment but YouTube
they've now made the platform even less
transparent with no more live subscriber
count' look at this right now why would
they do this why would they make it less
transparent because they want to make it
more difficult to see how this
blacklisting and shadow banning is
having an effect so they said we want to
direct people to verify channels we can
tell you objectively they're doing the
opposite and they've removed the ability
for it not just you publicly I think a
lot of you assume that we have some
tools that we don't we can't see whether
you're subscribing yeah we can't see
what's happening with our subscribers
how long you're staying they've made it
harder that's incredible so they're
becoming essentially some of the worst
propagandist machines that we've seen
throughout history and they're doing it
under the guise of work for you or for
the community right for helping
everybody out but this is just
propaganda what if it was the other way
around
what if only right-wing content was
going on right and that was it and left
wing was being muted and and here's
something else that's really unnerving
for me we don't know what it's going to
be yet there's an incoming new
harassment policy they're planning in
response by the way to the Vox had
pocalypse so I'm sorry that this
happened to the rest of you we weren't
looking for the ad pocalypse nope they
drew for his blood not me
but from CNBC Yeah right says the new
update comes just after Vox journalist
Carlos masa beautiful hombre former
that's spoke out in May about harassment
he said he experienced on the platform
at the hands of conservative commentator
Steven Treader after flip-flopping on
his policy YouTube ultimately has said
days later that would take a hard look
at our harassment policies with an aim
to update them okay so what constitutes
harassment hmm
and I know why don't you sit down with
your biggest conservative channel let us
know exactly we just never reached out
to by a guy named Brandon
and Brandon we've taught you've spoken
with Susan Wojcicki in the top brass at
YouTube we've met at random
no no Brandon nominate a gentleman named
Brandon and know he would be yet another
person who I'm sure will tell us yes
something's happening and don't worry
we're gonna see the information but we
just don't have enough people working
here we don't have enough skill to pull
the data
Brandon you're asking we don't have
enough people to be put on the biggest
controversy of the year as it relates to
content guidelines your number one
concern so you know you're just you're
on the back burner here's Brandon well
what does it know Brandon tell them I
don't know I'm an intern what do I know
I make it clear publish the guidelines
and we'll play ball listen if you tip if
you're if you're a publisher you're not
a private but you're not an open
platform then make it clear what you'll
publish that's we just want to
understand your rules so we know how to
play by them we can put the more
controversial content like I don't know
criticizing anyone on the LGBTQ move we
can put that behind mug club and make
sure there's just vanilla milk toast
you're on YouTube but you said you don't
want that because you're an open
platform yeah let us know and then we
know how we can move forward and let's
find common ground that's what we're
looking for and you know what let's move
a half-asian alert bill Richmond
let's move them over here so we can talk
about my legal action yeah come on over
and they're just keeping in a never
moving target right yeah it's just makes
it so much easier for them to hem and
haw and say oh we're just gonna kind of
go with the wind here and make it an
ever moving target so there's no actual
policy right so have it you know
half-asian yes thank you wonderful
sponsor well everyone out there try the
walther I just don't want it aimed at my
half-asian lawyers scrotum and testicles
crutch
what is it that we need to do what
actions are we we're going to be taking
because it's reached beyond the point of
just complaining well the you know it's
what's what's amazing about this the
every time we think you know certainly
this is the dumbest move that YouTube is
gonna make or this is the last action
they're gonna take behind the curtain or
to you know take invisible action behind
to do something especially considering
them as steps from the Vox ad pocalypse
they continue to do more and some of the
most recent things that you've seen and
that we talked about just now are you
know the the changes behind the scenes
that are only affecting not only louder
with crowd or butter effect
a whole slew of conservative voices and
as opposed to leftist voices and when we
have reached out continuously we haven't
seen anything haven't gotten that
information and so the next steps are
going to evolve a kind of multifaceted
one we already know that there's an
existing lawsuit that's been going on
from leftist groups and it specifically
LGBT groups and you know for those who
may be watching who are concerned about
well you know hey you know what I
actually don't care if you get throttled
but don't think about it of just this
view think about it if anyone can
throttle any political problem with the
LGBTQ lawsuit does they want an
injunction so that you cannot throttle
them but they also want YouTube to have
more strict policies regarding hate
speech to create a more safe space just
not us and that's the crazy part about
their their lawsuit is the inconsistency
there and don't ban us but make sure to
be on other people but the one part that
they do get right and that they go after
YouTube for is the inconsistency and the
lack of clarity about what the policies
are time and time again so we're gonna
take some action there decide the right
time to be able to you jump into the
fray on that side and go to the part
that really is an important point
because it does affect everyone any
political view whatsoever I think more
importantly than just political views
people in understand YouTube is the
central business model for a lot of
content creators yeah let's remove
politics from it this is how many people
make a living and don't make a living
directly on the monetization on YouTube
you use YouTube as an avenue to reach
people jumping-off point the biggest
biggest expense this company has ever
had outside of employee costs has been
running advertising on YouTube for a
long time they courted us and said they
created the advertising campaigns
millions of dollars and that's what's
crazy is that you know folks will always
say well you can just go to a different
platform you could just do something
different but they forget that all of
the creators especially louder Crowder
has spent in in you know in numerable
hours learning the system working on it
over the years building a subscriber
base they can't just follow anywhere
else and by the way flying out at their
dime flying out to YouTube Congress this
is important for you to know half-asian
bill Richmond went out with to account
and spoke with Susan Wojcicki before
that I went out and spoke with their top
legal we spoke with their their people
in charge of content folks
they invited us and when we were there
constant conversation was water that
what are the guidelines with well what
are we are we violating anything no no
no no no not at all we want diverse
voices then when we leave the
conference's we see a different story
playing and policies changed without us
knowing exactly and it's either it's
either their stories either gonna be
were been doing this deliberately or
it's gonna be we just didn't know what
was happening and that may be kind of
reminiscent of the Facebook battle that
actually brought us together that the
the idea that oh well it's just some
rogue employees put a policy together
the black listed a few conservative
voices and what's going on for years and
nobody knew about it up top some real
sorry but you did just we are going to
be taking action so yes so some of the
action is of course you know we can do
certain extent about that is but there's
multifaceted it's not just action we'll
take directly but the thing that you did
in the call to action to be able to say
hey you know pull up the examples your
own favorite conservative channels your
second favorite beyond a lot of times do
you if you want to help them and you
want to help us you want to help anyone
who has a political view whether it's
conservative or otherwise to force
YouTube you know here's the thing as we
know they're listening remember back to
the Vox apocalypse within a day even
less than a day of He Who Shall Not Be
Named who's beautiful a brave brave
posted about a complaint just a mere
complete we want how many zillions of
complaints they get and they knew that
that happened and they immediately took
action worked all weekend review all
your videos and now we can we get a
reach out again who this person is and
what they're actually gonna be actually
a cell phone video that hit a million
plays yes what's so sad and listen it
saddens me that that I mean I'm grateful
that we have this platform it but I
think of people where I was maybe six
years ago you know it's trying to grind
it out you guys aren't gonna be able to
make enough of a stink with the view
count for YouTube to answer I have a
lawyer on retainer your very expensive
by the way we have to stop that wing in
the new beach house and he can't get
return calls what gets a point of
contact is me putting a cell phone video
out and you guys sending in screenshots
so please keep doing it then then I
guess we'll try and talk with Brendan
brand Brandon not Brenda who you are
Brandon but here's in here Kevin oh it's
nothing personal I want to talk to the
manager
give me the manager my name is Karen
it's so the the idea that we're not
listening or they're unable to respond
or be able to do anything it's crazy but
what they do respond to is think about
all the comments that the folks have put
on to you know the videos and on to
tweets that have been able to have and
not only that the folks who continually
and repeatedly say you know what this is
the moment that I've joined mug club and
then a post about joining mug club right
directly if they're not gonna listen to
the following their own guidelines if
they're if YouTube isn't gonna listen to
just being intellectually honest I'm
definitely gonna listen when you hit
their pocketbook and let them know that
they're gonna have to go to a different
place where they know they can get the
content well thank you very much Jeff
engine builders gonna just so you know
we are going to be taking legal action
we can't talk about it a ton right now
because with something like this and I
see a lot of conservative lawsuits where
they just file them file them file we're
not litigious people it's bet once and
bet right yeah and so the more
information you can provide to us we
really appreciate it this is something
else to keep in mind they're not only
trying to alter the results of the 2020
election which they've openly expressed
this is this is YouTube also being upset
about Generation Z being more
conservative than other generations in
part because of social media and I don't
mean not all generation Z folks are
conservatives that's not I'm saying
right but if you compare them at this
stage in their life to baby boomers to
Gen Xers they are more conservative and
a big part of that is because of social
media you look at First Amendment you
look at Second Amendment issues you look
at neo feminist issues this is because
the left is overreached and now they
have access to the information so by the
way Silicon Valley calls this
radicalization what do they consider
radicalization that's why we're
radicalizing the youth apparently along
with philip defranco if you look at that
New York Times article radicalization is
apparently using someone's biologically
correct pronouns big tech wants to
change an entire worldview of a
generation that's why they don't want
you to see change my mind and here's the
thing if you can think of anything more
benign when people go out and preach hey
let's find common ground let's stop the
shouting matches let's stop the cable
news hyper edits where we're just
looking to score points if you can think
anything that crystallizes that more
effectively than change my mind
completely unedited on a campus with
students who are there of their own
volition you let me know because if
that's if change my mind is considered
radicalization to the point that YouTube
is going to try and ghost it from search
results well you know what I guess
the radicalize er of the youth and I'll
wear that title proudly half-asian alert
bill Richman thanks very much we must go
to Paul Joseph Watson yeah let's go
let's go
that is the question was this mannequin
answer for you
they chose a tumblr I was a temple was
the first facility he can't answer
because he's dead the tumblr killed him
it's not coming back think about
[Music]
whatever you want just take it and leave
don't leave I will use it I will shoot
what did you expect I am gonna sue you
so hard guilty what no I I don't
understand it
I'm sorry there's nothing I can do
firearms legal calm is flashing lwc if
you have a gun and you don't have this
you're an idiot again that's firearms
legal calm /lw see for 25 cents a day
you can buy bubblegum from a vending
machine for twenty four cents a day you
can feed a starving child
[Music]
but for $99 a year you can give a better
life to our motion graphics designer
Brendan Brendan need your help
he's never lived on his own before and
he's having trouble adapting because
brilliant motion graphics designers and
artists works who may be slightly on the
spectrum deserve a better life even
Brendan
[Music]
it's kind of unnerving
maybe unsettling is the word could be
for a child you don't know I'm about to
say it I'm just agreeing for a child to
threaten to stick up hmm well I mean it
especially in the wake of Trayvon it is
a little insensitive I don't think they
have this I don't think they understand
in Australia the context of that all
right I'm glad to have our next guest on
we haven't him on in a while let me give
you a hint as to who our next guest
he's a Globetrotter either that or he's
too cheap to afford a set but is not an
unfolded map you can follow him on
Twitter says prison planet his website
is summit dot news and more recently
banned dot video mr. Paul Joseph Watson
how are you sir I'm good Steve and how's
it going terribly now your your hair is
short so that's cool yeah so it had to
be cleaned up but you insist on having
the old sort of mock tap with a
cigarette in a lot of your display
pictures is that just because you know
that looks that's that's that's the
classical fasci haircut that's what the
media says in fact The Guardian wrote an
article the other day saying they were
afraid of Ivanka Trump's new haircut so
they're literally terrified by haircuts
at this point that's the level of the
deranged man syndrome what happens right
I tried to go floppy on top and with it
short sides back inside so that's a
normal fashion look how are they afraid
of Ivanka's haircut they said that it
proves that she's trying to rebrand
herself to be more credible because
she's about to run for office
so that's Hara fide oh okay so they're
scary because they think she could hold
office as opposed to holding sway over
the most powerful office in the land as
we see right now we see her fingerprints
all over it sometimes which I'll be
honest sometimes I'm not the biggest fan
of mr. Paul Joseph Watson this kind of
ties in with your website bans video and
we just talked about was sort of exposed
some of the new YouTube changes with
verified profiles and how difficult this
has been but you were telling me this
this all ties in together your video on
Greta
Burak by the way you Europeans you're
closer together like you're as far away
from Sweden as as Florida is from
California approximately have no idea is
it thin film soon Berg sunburn I mean I
I heard an actual Swedish person
pronounce it as something like Greta
Putin Berg I'm gonna try to appropriate
no well we don't care about the Swedes
well we can just do is we can start a
war and watch them do nothing yeah so
your video the one little bread we'll
call a little Greta it was he was
removed from YouTube entirely if I'm not
mistaken completely yeah and a warning
on the channel you tend not to now I
tend not to make a big deal out of these
things because it's just like a red flag
to a ball and then a bunch of people
don't try and flag all your other videos
to get others deleted but yeah it was a
video that was it was on the channel for
about two weeks had almost a million
views they banned it they removed it for
bullying and harassment
now the worst thing I did in that video
bearing in mind that Susan Wojcicki says
yes we welcome offensive content as if
they actually do that the worst thing I
said was to compare her style of
messaging and her appearance to some
kind of children of the corn situation
which funnily enough is what Laura
Ingraham did on her fox news show the
other night yeah yeah it was up for
about two weeks Bandai appealed it over
two weeks ago no response over two weeks
later and yes but I mean it's still on
[ __ ] shoe but it's permanently gone and
then obviously this disincentivizes you
criticizing her again
I could reload the video and remove a
couple of the slightly edgy insults this
is a well it would be illegal at all in
the UK who constantly talks about having
Asperger's or being on the autism
spectrum
but if you say that as Michael Knowles
did on Fox News and they caved in and
apologized he called her mentally ill
even though Asperger's is a quote
neurological disorder it is a mental
illness so if she's making that part of
her messaging and we can't even
reference it that's a double standard
right right and I do always love having
you on because know across the pond
cultural differences and you may be
vexed as to why the spokesperson I don't
want to
all of Fox News the spokesperson said
that and walked back that's because that
person at Fox is what we call here
stateside is a [ __ ] so I want to make
sure that we're clear yeah I don't think
Michael Knoll said anything wrong and I
try to be as objective as possible you
know there are some people who would
like you and you start talking about
Hitler and saying like it's not really
good to invoke his name he was you're
trying to say maybe some national policy
was good like yeah you veered into it
Michael Knoll said nothing wrong for
people who missed the story you know was
trending it was a flash in the pan
I was trending for a few minute there as
someone at Media Matters got a beat up I
just made it up they got a thorn in
their side Goodwin
got stuck in their craw the point is I
don't know what my point was but Michael
knows did nothing wrong in pointing out
that she has Asperger's and by the way
this is important remember Greta Greta
Limburg however they say it is the same
age as the Covington school kids now
people say well they were kind of dicks
first off I don't agree with it second
they were thrust into the media
spotlight against their will Greta chose
it and so I think that that opens one up
to valid criticism and if they're an
adult of age some ad hominem and good
fun well this is the point isn't it
Steven because the left exploits these
children as human shields for their
agenda and then they say oh by the way
they're beyond question
they then ban and can't cancel culture
people who dare challenge them and they
did the same with David hog a bunch of
videos on YouTube a bunch of channels
got taken down when people start
challenging what David hog was saying
but of course if it's a you know 16-year
old conservative kid in a manga hat
smirking then they're fair game for the
media to ruin their entire life right
there was another guy yesterday called
avi Yemeni you probably heard of him
yeah I know he did the Jim Jefferies
thing he was on the show yeah he was
banned he's gone he's done on Twitter
for saying Gratzer is being exploited by
the people around her and saying quote
she had an extremist message completely
banned his accounts gone it's not coming
back
so again they used it they use the
intimidation tactic of this D
platforming system that they've set up
and this canceled culture system to
shield their political propaganda to use
children as human shields and it's
insidious and it keeps happening over
over again well what's good good for the
goose is good for the gander I think I
have that one right Shields children as
shields Hamas they're not too far off so
birds of a feather I'm just gonna go on
be careful what you wish for look before
you now that's just a saps fables
those aren't Indians these are just
morals too horrible fairy tales and it's
not a fairy tale it's the other aspects
of this in using those kids as human
shields they're also traumatizing an
entire generation of young people a lot
of psychologists in the UK are talking
about this now this new phenomenon of
climber anxiety or eco anxiety yeah
where children are literally being told
that everyone's going to be dead in 12
years of course we know that's abject
nonsense
even one of the head authors of the IPCC
report for the UN Myles Allen called out
greater the other day for being alarmist
because of course as this whole debate
about a 1.5 degree warming by 2040 of
course there are a bunch of other
factors there even take into account in
that but again they're literally
traumatizing kids dragging them to
protests they're crying in the streets
thinking that parents their friends and
themselves are going to be dead within
12 years when even the IPCC report says
well maybe the problems will start in 12
years and of course aoc echoed this with
her Green Deal thing yes dream deal I
appreciate that you are so dismissive
because I think it was a new deal
because it's five pages and has an
addendum that says and social justice
for all that's why it's silly yeah and I
mean the other thing is again these are
the some of the same people who fear
monger about a new ice age in the 70s
you know Newsweek Time magazine they
told us people like Paul Ehrlich the
overpopulation will lead to mass
starvation that was the dominant
consensus scientific opinion for years
and years in the late 70s none of it
happened so why should we believe them
now and then it's just it's the
hypocrisy of it that stenches she's
piling around with Arnold Schwarzenegger
a dude who literally has a garage full
of muscle cars and tanks you know she's
prowling around with Leonardo DiCaprio a
dude who takes private jets to collect
environmental Awards Prynne
hairy's up there on the stage with her
he took for private jet trips in 11 days
he wasn't on a mission to save the
planet he was parting Elton John's
mansion well here I am you know like
washing out my jam jars and recycling my
plastic Evian bottles I'm taking a
handful of commercial plane trips a year
but I'm bad and I need to be lectured
forget about India and China they're
fine
well to be fair Prince Harry was I mean
he was there was a two-for-one special
at Bosley now let me you mention this
with YouTube and we're going to go to
web extended in a few minutes have you
been following the changes here with
YouTube's and save now they've now said
that they're going to try to direct
people towards verified accounts we've
talked about this where if just just
early right you probably didn't see it
um where if you search our video name
with my name it doesn't show up you'll
see other channels before and this
didn't happen before and of course we've
never received any answer from YouTube
it's getting to be pretty severe and now
of course I don't know if you've read
about this or what you're expecting from
the new harassment policy that should be
forthcoming but that's very scary to me
I didn't read about the new harassment
policy and that's gonna get them in
trouble based on the fact that some of
the biggest creators on YouTube are
drama people who literally pick fights
and in some cases staged fights with
each other and have these back-and-forth
insults and of course boxing matches and
everything else right and that's the
entire basis of their channel and these
people have got in upwards of 10 million
subscribers some of them so they're
gonna have problems with that the thing
about the the search and the YouTube
election blacklist which you tweeted
about I checked your channel about an
hour ago and I think maybe because you
made a big deal out of it it's gone back
and its flipped back where if you do
search steven crowder change my mind
your videos do come up hmm for the past
I would say probably four to six months
you can go on Google itself of course
Google owns YouTube search my name Paul
Joseph Watson YouTube for the past four
to six months not only was my channel
like buried down the first page or on
page two it was not even returned on
Google search results this is a channel
with over 1.7 million subscribers they
completely buried it they broke
our own search engine just so people
couldn't find my channel and I I was
getting messages saying what a shame you
don't make youtube videos anymore I
haven't seen them in months stars
getting good views cuz the emails are
still going out to the subscribers but
it was completely expunged from a google
search itself it only came back a few
days ago and it's like an off link to an
uploads playlist it's not even the front
page of the channel but they literally
changed the algorithm and they did this
with other creators as well as you for a
time I'm sorry I blamed that because I
think a large part of it is I do the vox
ad pocalypse and they made some changes
and it's it's not what I wanted but you
know I apologize I don't know but we
kept the bleep business you mean the
beautiful and brave the beautiful and
brave member of the LGBTQ community from
the the stellar journalists at Fox
that's what you meant to say make sure
they have it right yes and you know
we're gonna go to a web extender here
for people who do not follow our guest
prison planet but then his website is
summit dot news band dot is it band dot
video band up video yeah band yeah we do
get band come on I think I don't think
so I mean I think that they probably
would ban you but you know just look at
that wonderful punim still not Jewish
folks we are going to go to a web
extended I want to talk about some of
the measures that you've had to take in
order to sort of circumvent these
different changes to the algorithms that
come up almost every other day it seems
now so thank you so much we're gonna
continue close this up and then web
extended if those are in Mudd Club if
you are if you're not you don't see it
[Music]
[Music]
you're not dying you just can't think of
anything fun to do join mug lemon lotto
with CARICOM slash Muslim time for the
one live read of the week in case you
were surprised well I want to talk about
my club but listen thank you so much to
Walter our wonderful sponsor they've
never bet it and I hear amidst all this
controversy and it's one of the sponsors
that they came into the show because I
reached out to them because I owned
Walters and I love them and and if you
guys don't firearms out there if you're
looking into a firearm I say it's like
Mercedes BMW Porsche at a certain point
they're all really good I'm not going to
denigrate other firearm companies but I
do prefer the Walter just Google Walther
PPQ reviews just just Google and see the
kind of feedback that they get and when
you go to a range try the Walter they
have the balls to support this show and
if you want to support this show the
only way to do it since we're
demonetised is mug Club louder with
credit calm slash mug Club ninety-nine
dollars annually you get this sounds
like at a stroke and then the 69 for
students veterans active military you
get this hand etched mug eighty percent
more content from this show a daily show
along with dave rubin along with
everyone else over there at the blaze TV
we really try to make it a value-added
proposition so thank you for the support
please do join up at la Torre's credit
calm slash mug Club if you don't check
this page every single day we upload a
video every night except Sunday thanks
[Music]
it's funny sometimes American
journalists talk about how bad a country
is good people are lining up food that's
a good thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bring Santa's
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's called the fat kid at the pool
who puts in a t-shirt because he's
self-conscious no one no one buys it
Kyle I was that kid at one point I wear
a t-shirt you like it and then no you're
not you're not that trust me at this
point and then and then I realized that
the wet t-shirt the wet sheer t-shirts
that my toes are puffy nipples yes that
much is far more unflattering than just
biting the bullet yeah just by the way
thank you to everyone out there who so
readily fat shamed me upon request left
my heart watching people who missed it
of course go to the web extended join
mug club thank you guys so much as we
talk about this we don't know what's
going to happen we do know that if you
want to continue watching this content
for free even on YouTube you it goes
away without mug club and that actually
kind of brings me to something I wanted
to talk about this week I guess let me
state this just on the outset and then
work my way backwards because I've
talked about this before that's kind of
how I learned give me give me the
concept concept learned that's how I
learn give me the concept geez I don't
know what happened there they have a
stroke
I always how I learned give me the
concept and don't sort of work my way
backwards I cannot do things step by
step talked about this with instruction
manuals whether it's building a grill or
putting together some some you know
Greta Greta as a furniture there you
know a bookcase it's not another reason
to not be a big fan of Sweden I've been
incredibly reserved by the way in our
addressing of Greta I think that if I'm
a public figure to be honest get away
with nothing more than a comparison to
Stephen Merchant
it's basically unscathed thumbs the
compliment it's almost a compliment so
let me give you that so that we can work
away backwards there is no virtue in
being vulnerable what does that mean let
me explain it we hear this a lot you
know if you well this is it's
beautifulest person was being so
vulnerable there's nothing good about
being vulnerable for the sake of being
vulnerable it's the wrong word it's the
wrong
raise and it's important let me explain
why I'm guilty of using this by the way
here's an example when I used to get
hurt early on in my marriage I've talked
about this I would often express it I
think a lot of men do through anger I
had someone tell me that you know most
women don't really respond well to anger
and I don't mean anger necessarily
directed at my wife but overall anger
frustration anger is usually kind of a
dishonest emotion it veils what's
actually hurting you and so the same
person told me that it would be more
effective to be vulnerable with my wife
to express what was bothering me and the
advice was write contextually the
wording was not same thing with you've
heard me talk about it this week mental
health issues
I've openly talked about my struggles on
here because you know I do believe or at
least I hope that it can help people
often we've talked about that people
just trot out a kind of a me-too when a
celebrity dies from mental health issues
or whenever it becomes the topic du jour
because there's been some kind of a mass
shooting and it rings hollow I know as
someone who's had to deal with it
it doesn't help anyone I go well you're
just saying that because of Heath Ledger
and you're you're trying to tap into a
trend right now it doesn't help anyone
so I to think mainly because this is
what I was told that in being open about
my struggles I was making a conscious
decision to be vulnerable technically I
was but that wasn't the reason we hear
it all the time right I just I had to
come with someone was saying this the
other day that's what kind of spurred
this thought I had to come to a really
honest place with this peace and be
vulnerable and whatever to say peace and
that's how you know doesn't really mean
anything that could be anything from
abstract theater to a character in a
film to poop literally on a canvas that
you have been awarded some kind of
postmodern prize for I just I just had
to be vulnerable we hear this all the
time and everyone goes oh that that's so
brave that's so brave exposing your
vulnerability like that and it's gotten
to the point where we almost seem to
seek opportunities to be vulnerable and
as a society now we reward vulnerability
for vulnerabilities sake and it's
bullcrap
I think it's important to point out why
this is bullcrap one reason is not the
least of which it confuses young men and
women short but for right now I'll speak
to what I know a little better no penis
no opinion young men don't want to be
vulnerable it's not a desirable place to
be and that's not societal conditioning
it's an innate defense mechanism it's
hardwired in and so these young men who
hear this mantra just be vulnerable just
be vulnerable they often feel confused
what because in trying to make young men
feel safe we've actually just delivered
a message that gilts them into feeling
conflicted about their biological
instincts it's also wrong because it's
attaching virtue to a concept where none
actually exists just like when we as a
society shun all violence including
righteous violence
what kind of example I don't know ending
the Holocaust stopping a rape not all
violence is equivalent so just just as
when we shun all violence praising all
vulnerability it does a remarkable
disservice as to why those vulnerable
instances are valuable in the first
place and hint it's not because of the
vulnerability itself some vulnerability
is stupid you reveal your soft
underbelly to an enemy who wants to kill
you you're dead that's it no one's gonna
be praising you for how vulnerable you
were in your eulogy is it your eulogy
are you the one delivering a eulogy
you're affected audio Wade I saw get low
and ears if you find yourself constantly
and maybe I guess unwittingly or
uncaring Lee being vulnerable you will
be perceived as weak and you'll
ultimately begin to feel weak so what's
the virtue here why is it better to be
vulnerable with your wife and to be
angry why is it productive to talk about
mental health issues which people may
use against you let me laser in it's not
about vulnerability it's about truth and
if you watch this show that shouldn't
come as a surprise to put a finer point
on it it's a rather than vulnerability
it's about telling the truth
or living truthfully even when you know
it will be immensely uncomfortable so
see whatnot when I would get angry and I
just yell or I'd storm off and a fight
with my wife the truth is that I was
hurt that I was damaged but because that
truth was so uncomfortable to face I
instead chose to smokescreen it with
rage see vulnerability there was a
byproduct of honesty for a long time you
know what I never did I never did
discuss my struggles with mental health
issues with with depression things like
that why because I know that in today's
political climate despite it being a
favored talking point of the left which
we know you love that it could
ultimately be used against me and I've
always known you know in a lot of ways
that I'm abnormal and the truth is being
abnormal isn't always fun acknowledging
it is even less fun taking steps to work
within those boundaries and finding
acceptance within those limitations is
even less fun so the truth there
involves exposing my flaws to the world
not for the sake of vulnerability but
because speaking the truth is the right
thing to do and it can help people if
it's if it saves one life great and if I
have the ability or the opportunity to
save one life by simply facing the truth
that is my duty regardless of
vulnerability it's it's the duty of all
of us it's yours I cannot stress this
enough and this is why so many young
people specifically men are confused
they've been bombarded with these ideas
of toxic masculinity or the the concept
of it's sort of all been merged into
this amalgam it of false machismo and in
an attempt to sort of I guess stifle the
righteous indignation of young men which
is how we're designed we fill their
heads with visions of weakness as though
it's something to be emulated so that
they can shed their skin of ego and they
can live an enlightened life it's
[ __ ] you can be vulnerable and
simultaneously be wrong
even evil the flip side of that you can
be strong and simultaneously right and
good
it doesn't change a damn thing the
vulnerability it comes down to truth it
comes down to doing the right thing
regardless of the comfort level so
here's the exercise for this week okay I
want you to take a minute take inventory
maybe do a scan do an internal scan of
some things that have been holding you
back I don't know maybe maybe in the
back of your head there's been this
voice nagging e to do something you've
been too afraid to do it maybe it's
addiction maybe it's depression maybe
it's a holding pattern that you don't
know how to break it doesn't know what
it is
I want you to think of something that
you need help with that you've been
putting off something difficult positive
you got you got it okay now I want you
to go share that with someone someone
you trust ask for help ask for advice
seek wise counsel start the process of
healing start the process of creating
and executing a solution sure you'll
you'll feel vulnerable because you are
vulnerable but be mindful that you're
doing it not for the sake of
vulnerability but because you are being
honest and it's the right thing to do
regardless of how unpleasant it may be
because someone who makes themselves
vulnerable without honesty is just a
fool
I hope that helps maybe it doesn't see
you next week
[Music]